okay so today um we are
going to be reacting to something that
kevin samuel said before he passed so um
when kevin sam and this is rest in peace
kevin samuels
so
great man great man but this is
something that he said before he passed
away that when he passed had a lot of
people in uproar so um we are going to
react to the clip if you could pull it
up-ish
and give our thoughts okay but if you
have made it to 35 years old and you're
unmarried
you are a leftover woman
a left over woman you are what is left
men know that there is something likely
wrong with you whether you want to hear
it or not i'm going to just go there
with you i'm telling you the truth that
you don't want to hear
men know that there is something likely
wrong with you
but you cannot be
fit in
an adjustable six or higher 35 unmarried
something wrong with you
that's where men automatically coming at
it and here's the thing
just like when you were between the ages
of 18 and uh 25 and you didn't want to
settle
you were trying to get them you were
trying to get the ceo the pilot the
investment banker you were trying to get
fluid out
here's what's going to happen if you are
a woman 35 plus
[Music]
and you want a man that's
uh
on the same lifestyle level you're going
to have to share it so i want to start
and give your initial
thoughts to this video starting with you
and then go around
starting with me
35
you're left over
you're done out here
i i just agree wholeheartedly with what
you're saying oh you disagree no i agree
oh you agree you just agree so you think
it's over at 35.35
you know there's all these people
calling themselves tens i'm just curious
how old are you
40. 40. so how was how old would you
date younger
how about would i date yeah yeah
30 30. okay is that is that how old your
girlfriend is no
oh okay my missus is my age oh okay
we're big people out here okay
i was just wondering yeah yeah yeah no
worries
okay what about you
um
i personally disagree
um i'm 21 so i don't have that much
experience in like the relation
dating game and everything like that but
i feel like in my generation and like
moving forward
um
i don't think that's possible because
it's like we have people that
are like public figures for example like
just sees an example like kim kardashian
she's like 40 years old
and she's still dating she was in a
relationship like she was married for
like how long and it's like outside of
that you know her breaking up with her
husband and everything
she's still like kind of moving on
still dating i don't think 35 i think 45
is too young for you to say that you're
left over
i feel like that's still a bit too young
but that's just my opinion okay what do
you think
um i don't think i agree with the term
leftover in general
and i also don't think you should put an
age on what your term is left over um i
think it's
i don't i think age is irrelevant i
think it's completely based on who you
are character
all the different other attributes aside
from age like just to say because
someone's a certain age they're left
over women i think that's i completely
disagree completely disagree that's my
stance
i agree
you agree why yeah as a mom and i agree
because most women over 35 who are
single have issues
okay i was
five at one point and i had issues like
you know they've got issues i mean
you're 35.
either
if you're a virgin
i can't understand why or then you're
not left over but if you're 35 and
you've lived life
and you've been through life
why should a man want you i mean
everybody's looking at all these artists
and all these stars
that's not reality that's just one-off
but at 35
i did she was at 35 so i can understand
that if you're not married at 35 or in a
stable relationship has to be something
wrong with you otherwise why aren't you
in a relationship if you're that great
we go ahead what do you guys think um
but in the in the video that we saw he
didn't say relationship i said he said
if you're not married so would you say
it's different if you're in a
relationship
that
if you're good enough to be in a
long-term relationship you're good
enough to get married and if you're not
why ain't you
not everybody aspires to marriage though
that's very true that's the problem
i don't necessarily think it's a problem
i just think that it's a different i
think over the different generations
there's different views for instance a
lot of the women and girls i speak to
you my age say they put off marriage and
having children till they're in their
30s so i think
times have changed in terms of for
instance myself
i would consider
marriage in my 30s like and if i got to
35 and i wasn't married i wouldn't i
wouldn't necessarily see it as a problem
and that there's something wrong with me
um
yeah i see i think just assuming that
there's something wrong with someone
that's not married at 35 is just
i think it's oversimplifying everything
and i completely disagree again
why don't you say though it's it's
if
we wouldn't you want to be married if
there was a guy that checked all your
boxes would you not would you not want
to marry him
i mean if i feel like if it made sense
then yeah
i don't feel like people should well
firstly i don't think people should rush
into marriage firstly like i feel like
you should that kind of takes time when
it comes to that kind of stuff but yeah
like if i have found someone that
literally took through my boxes and all
of that stuff 100
so then by that logic wouldn't you say
that the the women that aren't picked by
35 like the best guys picked the younger
women and left everyone else over
like in a way
because because if you survey men
between the ages of 20 and 80 and you
ask like what age do they find the most
attractive all of them find that ages
between like 21 to 24 is like a girl's
peak
and um 90 of your eggs are gone by 30
and 50 of your options are gone by 30.
i wouldn't say you should say there's a
peak time i i feel like when you're
saying there's a peak time you're basing
it on looks primarily
um i think there's so much more like you
don't marry someone just based on looks
and between the ages of 21 to 24 that
could be your peak but you're finding
yourself so how can you say that okay a
man should pick a woman at that age but
she doesn't even know who she is yet i
feel like when once you put an age on
these things that's where like
divorce tends to come in divorce rates
are so high
i think because you're putting in you're
putting time pressure on it i don't
think there needs to be a time pressure
and sorry going back to your point about
if a guy ticked all my boxes now again i
wouldn't say that i'm ready um because i
feel like i'm still finding myself at
the age of 21. um you haven't
experienced life you haven't done a lot
of things
and
again this is why i don't think aid
should be
the fact what we measure it by because
someone could be 35 and they haven't
experienced life as much as someone
who's
25 and that's a 10 10 year age gap and
they could have had completely different
life experiences so yeah i think
my problem is putting a time on it so in
terms of age i think that's where the
problem is so do you not think it starts
with looks
yeah i think it starts but it will stop
at a certain point like it will not be
long lasting if it's just based
primarily on looks so